i'm trying to win my medical i'm not
going in there to win the 40. not trying
to win the the
bench press you know my main focus is to
recover as much as i can you know
leading up to that process right where i
can i can win my my medical so yeah
that's what i'm looking for what do you
say to the the pushback that you may get
when you meet with his team so you know
they try to get under your skin and they
want to see how you react what what are
you going to say when the general
manager says hey to it you know
everything looks good you look healthy
but
three lower body injuries at alabama
it's a big boy league now if you can't
stay healthy there you're not going to
stay healthy yeah what are you going to
say when they start pushing you that way
whoa i wasn't bionic then i'm bionic now
i like it
that was to the tonga hello we had a
great time with him three weeks ago at
the super bowl got a great vibe from him
seems like a really nice man i'm trying
to resist saying kid these guys are
younger than my kids young gentlemen
they are younger than my child i cannot
process this i remember when i noticed
in the late 80s that some of these guys
being drafted were younger than me that
was bad enough now i'm noticing they are
younger than my son so i'm resisting
calling them kids but i refer to my son
as my kid
you're old sorry old man river sorry
there y'all van you
i'm not turning 40 this year you are
yeah i know
so you better get used to it because
it's coming it's a damn shame i know
it's yeah i can't believe it how could i
be 40 years old i don't even understand
that how could that have happened i'm
gonna get you for your birthday a
lifetime supply of suntan lotion okay
thank you i'll take it i need it
for a guy who went to texas and then
played in tampa the whitest guy in
america i ended up in the two places
with the hottest damn son ever
uh all right um we we played that clip
from tuatanga by low because nick saban
the
head coach at alabama who does not want
to put excessive pressure on tuatango
vailoa has put
excessive pressure onto a tonga by loa i
think he's a lot like drew brees saban
says i always thought aaron rodgers was
a lot like that as a player too not
overly big accurate with the ball really
good judgment decision making those guys
are that style of player i would never
say the expectation should be he would
accomplish what those guys have i'd
never want to put that on a guy but
that's the style of player is so i don't
want to put that pressure on him but
he's drew brees or aaron rodgers and let
me tell you nick you're on the list now
with aaron rodgers do not say aaron
rodgers isn't big remember that clip
where i think it was from the 60 minutes
interview where he had a meet and greet
with a fan and the fan comes up and says
oh you're not as big as i thought and
roger says i don't like that yeah i mean
rogers is not short right you stood next
to him on on the uh you're walking down
the fairway right in in lake tahoe he's
not like 5 11. no he's he's like six two
and a half and and you know forget that
it's rogers has the arms of like the the
arms of like a six eight guy and he's
got the hands of like a six eight human
being so he has attributes like that
that make him play bigger than his
actual size and i know what nick saban's
saying there he's saying yeah this is
not like you know this huge guy standing
in the pocket big ben peyton manning cam
newton no it's not that kind of guy this
is a guy who could stand in the pocket
and make throws but is also a very good
athlete like drew brees and aaron
rodgers and twitchy that way can hop
around the pocket can escape the procket
and and scramble and do those things as
well and that's where tua can be good
you know it's just going to be about hey
tu is talented there's no doubt he's a
top five talent uh but the the medical
and how he measures up to a justin
herbert and joe burrow and all those
things are going to be you know big
factors to exactly where he goes in the
top 10 or the top 15 if there's injury
concerns
it's a shame you take away that that hip
injury and i don't know maybe joe burrow
would have supplanted him as the
presumed number one pick but you know
you've heard talk about the dolphins at
number five armando soguero the miami
herald reported yesterday that justin
herbert is the guy that the dolphins are
starting to warm up to and who knows
whether that's true or not maybe they
want someone to jump them to take
herbert soto will still be there but i
think we may see chris three
quarterbacks taken in the top five this
year i think so joe burrow justin
herbert and two tonga villa yeah i mean
if you made me bet right now two it
would be the one i would question the
most just because of the injury but i'm
with you mike i think it's gonna be
those three you know i think as people
continue like i said but justin urban
they're going to continue to evaluate
and they're going to be more and more
impressed they're going to realize his
negatives are not him but some of the
offense he was trying to run so it
should be fun to watch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports